hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with Wade my good buddy
Wade also known as Lord minion seven
seven seven on YouTube high noon Wade
good how are you doing mark whoa that
was like a well yeah he's like right in
my ear blasting although I play alone a
lot so I'm not used to another person
well yeah we got to talk about it for
the mic to pick up and don't really
louder than me I know but I'm trying to
be calm and close because this game is
about skill and precision what is it
it's also known as Russell jump where we
play as two Mexican wrestlers trying to
slam each other's bodies into the ground
and then Pilate drive each other but the
best part is it's only controlled by two
buttons so it's easy enough for even you
to play yeah what age oh god I don't
know whoa no no no no nice pelvis
throttle yeah this game um I just found
it the other day and it's just working
off oh how is that me oh no maybe cuz
you're new at the game either oh my god
this is an easy game to play oh god oh
god oh god oh yeah why cuz we both
jumped okay you're just gonna slide down
the nose I see oh yeah yeah never easy
isn't easy easy
pop none oh yeah just come back to yeah
whatever you only need to win one wait
this sounds familiar
was there a Dalek thing where I only
need him so I'm good yeah there was a
dime cake thing all right when I was
back in Cincinnati and played I've taken
we had a little dare to chuck some wing
sauce wasn't exactly hot but it was
still disgusting when you take like that
much of it in one slow it was like
drinking soup so thick wings soup it was
little my god and it was she's lucky
here we go again now that you have
practice you know what's going yeah I
pressed the button yeah yeah oh yeah
also proo are you doing anything or you
just gotta get water okay we could
reenact this pressed up against the wall
if you want yeah strip down in our
skivvies oil each other up and hold
hands another pelvic thrust at each
other are you sure
Oh Oh God what am i doing Oh
oh I can touch a cha-cha-cha real good
oh yes yes no no like being a Mexican
wrestle no cuz I know you killed
yourself you're not good at know your
thing we didn't show that secret whoa
hello oh good thing we didn't show that
secret uh no no well you just keep
killing yourself I don't do a damn thing
no I was insulting you I wasn't looking
oh stop it I'm trying to make fun of you
don't you know well I can see that's
what happens
you let that big pelvic bulge you got on
the front of your it was the lightest of
taps against wall and you're dead no no
no oh no no no no no man I wish we were
doing a dare because I wouldn't have to
do it David shaking gallon yeah no this
is practice I got like uh screen cleaner
we could chug it probably not kill you
wet wet it probably not kill you I heard
you I said wet instead of what I don't
know what wet wet wet just shouting in
the middle of a parking lot what what
what what why should we see a parking
lot not like a crowded restaurant oh
this is our normal venue to do these
random weird things just holding up a
bottle of monster cleaner in the gun
I'm the monster cleaner monster you want
to lose again yeah alright one more time
okay so the strategy is to not suck no
when do not wrestle and when to wrestle
long ah yeah baloney I had you in the
palm of my crotch wow I am so good at
this my foot was down I'm so good no
you're just killing yourself I don't
need to do a damn thing here
whoops listen o BK me
nope it's real dawn fine best seven out
of 15 way we've heard I've already won
four oh wait hope ya like a wimpiest
thing I've ever seen in my life yeah Wow
who's not all or another Louie
ah this is bull what I've known my skill
hey oh oh wow the bull no no no
nomination oh no since he lost so
severely in this round we're gonna move
on to another game that requires equal
amounts of skill and look little to do
there's the transition yes that was what
it was that was applied transition
anyway here I be r BR bit like you ad
throw off my groover
what do you see you're doing Wow red
card whatever soccer means jump on your
head no no yeah yeah oh no they hump it
oh god no yeah where I'll take it now
we're after that oh yeah you'll never
get across the hole my favorite I love
it okay welcome back everybody now we
got a new game to hopefully redeem
Wade's welcome back everybody we got
another game here to hopefully redeem
weights
poor poor performance in his last game
well not bad it was pretty bad you lost
like four to one a nice game you're just
gonna be totally squashed but we've
upped the difficulty level we actually
have two buttons now to Kin crease it
complexity it's soccer but each of us
controls one player with one button does
that make any sense
tons we did one practice round let's see
I'll go it was bad what's your damn
buttons Oh get over still five win hey
this is gonna be the grunting let's play
oh what'd you go I'm working my way way
downtown make my way down oh no guys
score and oh oh can you get your other
guy out of my face no what would you got
a problem with me being a new buddy no
no no yeah yeah just wait I got time you
know you guys jumped you [ __ ] oh god
what am i doing
let's hang on I'm on my way hey you do
have fun over there all right yeah you
look good you look a little something
I'm fine you sure you're okay so I
always can uh hey guys
this'll be yeah you uh yeah good yeah
yeah yeah I talk
Oh shirtless now bunk up come on up up
now
you scored one and you didn't leave it
you give it up yes lass hmm get in that
be aa good have no huge go huh huh yeah
suck where my Joe I don't know he's in
the goal young by one guy in real cool
you're not even doing anything with her
other man he's gone fun oh oh oh God
your heads go I don't know what's real
good Oh and yep let's do bear with me go
sailing into the goal
my other guy's gonna take care of
everything we're just gonna have a
moment here so just don't mind oh hello
hey we're just gonna all of us we're
just a little okay no just gonna
practice my peas and up though oh well
my players were having a tender moment
okay this time don't embarrass yourself
in front I got I've already pressed my
buttons hey good maybe you need to
intelligently pray all mine you should
lose a point for that
No maybe you should lose them brain for
me Wow bird Oh sick defense markiplier
thank you me sick defense mode boy shut
up right now
woo futbol americano uh mom's distracted
you that I I screw to go
no young guys like looking at here to
play some offense man you're not doing
anything good okay hi you want to come
near me bro yeah I'm coming near me oh I
touch the log just fall you could do get
it no I know we're on opposing teams
right now but I just want to tell you
have beautiful eyes thank you so do you
they look black and scary up close but
you know oh the show okay I'm gonna come
over there no bar
don't bother you sure yeah are you gonna
do oh yeah yeah do that dance a little
bit my gosh discuss all can't beat the
break dancing duo oh yeah oh god yeah
move Son do you think a guy gives me
hope
yeah he's in yourself Oh prematurely 500
units of real oh he's got room together
whoa oh my god go is that power before
you think you got up messing me yeah so
much still funk yep no thank you thank
you for the assist you're welcome I'm
great at game everyone yeah wow wow it
was not we're doing huh yeah capstan
yeah
yeah Shelby yeah I don't know what's
your straddling you're not doing
anything jump in oh yeah oh yeah big Ken
I'm like Michael Jordan oh really
no I'm gonna score so many goals oh no
no no no yeah yeah yeah gang banging my
goal fairly you're done you're done you
can't eat oh yeah
four to five okay all comes down to here
no this is the word why anti-climactic
within toad anyway I have instability so
anyway I was thoroughly embarrassed wade
here and he is going to go crying home
to his mom but not after not before
doing our charity livestream tomorrow at
9 a.m. Pacific Standard Time that'swell
p.m. Eastern Standard Time that's like
3:00 in the afternoon in Europe no 5:00
in the afternoon in Britain sorry if
it's here in another part of the world
you can't make the whole thing but we
will be doing a lot of fun stuff Bob
will also be here he's flying later
today
so thank you all so much for watching
thank you wait for being here check out
his video channel in the I'm bad out
roses it's ok for a positive time thanks
again everybody watching it as always
we'll see you
be twice as much as he ever loved you
shut up you're another other complicated
man